[music]
[singing]
Mcebo Maziya:
[speaking in Xhosa]
My name is Mcebo Maziya.
Mcebo Maziya:
I am Xhosa by cultural heritage,
as that is my tribe.
Mcebo Maziya:
And I'm from South Africa.
Kamelia Lechani:
[speaking in Arabic]
Hello. My name is Kamelia Lechani,
from Morocco.
Kiiru "Sam" Gichohi:
[speaking in Swahili]
My name is Kiiru Gichohi,
also known as Sam.
Mattie Lillian Maboya:
[Speaking in Pedi]
My name is Mattie Lillian Maboya, and I
Mattie Lillian Maboya:
am from South Africa.
Courage Matiza:
[Speaking in Shona]
Hi, my name is Courage Matiza.
Courage Matiza:
I am from Zimbabwe.
Kamelia Lechani:
Most of us here just graduated from ALA,
and we are getting ready
to go to college.
Fred Swaniker:
I think it's a great time to be a young African right now.
Because Africa today is maybe what
China was 20 or 30 years ago.
Fred Swaniker:
It's just starting to take off.
These young people are the ones
who are going to be able
Fred Swaniker:
to capture these opportunities.
[singing]
Julio Blaise Maniratunga:
So, what people would hear about leadership,
they may think it's only
about politics and stuff,
but it's actually almost in anything.
[bus and crowd noises]
Fred Swaniker:
A leader's effectiveness is only partly a
function of their skills.
Fred Swaniker:
A huge part of the effectiveness
is the quality
Fred Swaniker:
of the networks that they have.
And the most powerful
Fred Swaniker:
network that these young leaders
have is actually with each other.
Heather Haynes:
["Welcome" in several languages.]
Welcome.
[waterfall]
Steve Boehlke:
The most enduring way to impact
leadership behavior is through
what I call "breakthrough
Steve Boehlke:
awareness," where the
light bulb goes on.
Steve Boehlke:
And that's what's terrific about
the opportunities to
Steve Boehlke:
work in the outdoors that the
Blairstown Center provides.
Bryan Pannill:
All you really have is yourself, the board,
and the island.
Particpant:
That's good.
Lower it.
Olivia Iloetonma:
Being at the Princeton-Blairstown
Center, surrounded with such
support, gave me the ability
Olivia Iloetonma:
to have the courage to step up
and do something I've never
Olivia Iloetonma:
done before.
Courage Matiza:
We basically had to travel from one tree to
another on a steel wire.
Mattie Lillian Maboya:
I felt like I can do it.
Like, if all these people think that I
can do it, why not?
Mcebo Maziya:
What I learned today was the power
of respect for one another.
Mcebo Maziya:
The power of taking
responsibility for your actions.
Mcebo Maziya:
And the power of cooperation.
Because you can't make
a big change alone.
Chris Bradford:
One of the great things about working
with these young leaders is that
they will start to draw
Chris Bradford:
connections between different
fields as they build
Chris Bradford:
organizations with far-reaching
impact.
Chris Bradford:
So we're looking not only for
the people who will build the
Chris Bradford:
Googles of Africa, but also for
the prominent writers of
Chris Bradford:
the future, or artists.
And if we can bring them into
one network, we think that
Chris Bradford:
they can collaborate through
their lives to create a very
Chris Bradford:
different Africa.
Kiiru "Sam" Gichohi:
You can only handle a network of 120
people in your life
at any given time.
Kiiru "Sam" Gichohi:
And I plan on finding the 120
people who matter most to me
Kiiru "Sam" Gichohi:
in the world, and in those 120
people, to find the five or
Kiiru "Sam" Gichohi:
seven who make me a better
person every day.
[cicadas humming, crowd noise]
Linda Kay Klein:
So today, we're going to talk a little bit about home.
Courage Matiza:
This session basically helped me to really
look and say, "OK, this is
what I've received.
Courage Matiza:
What is it that I want to
embrace, and what is that I
Courage Matiza:
want to release?"
[cicadas humming, crowd noise]
Chris Bradford:
What we're trying to do is connect these
amazing young leaders with
individuals who can help them
Chris Bradford:
make their dreams become a reality.
Shirley M. Tilghman:
It is so inspiring to see the students
who are setting as one of their
goals, to become the
Shirley M. Tilghman:
generation of leaders who are
going to really make Africa a
Shirley M. Tilghman:
place that is prosperous and
healthy and forward-thinking
Shirley M. Tilghman:
for all of its people.
It is a mission that we resonate
with very much here
Shirley M. Tilghman:
at Princeton,
not just leaders for Africa, but
the importance of leaders
Shirley M. Tilghman:
to get us through these very,
very stormy times.
[crowd noise]
Andrew McLaughlin:
What social networks do very well, online
social networks, is that they
make weak ties easy.
Andrew McLaughlin:
Since the fall of Mubarak, the
national sound of Egypt is the
Andrew McLaughlin:
sound of chairs being pulled
together in a circle.
Andrew McLaughlin:
The weak ties of the online
social world are becoming
Andrew McLaughlin:
stronger ties as people get to
know each other face to face
Andrew McLaughlin:
in real life.
Mbali Palisa Zondi:
When I go back, I, too, want to make a difference.
Courage Matiza:
I've just learned that I'm not alone.
There's a lot of people
out there who are
Courage Matiza:
waiting to help me.
I just need to ask them.
Olivia Iloetonma:
To see it in myself, to stand up and take
initiative and move forward --
Olivia Iloetonma:
follow the road not taken, as
Robert Frost would say --
Olivia Iloetonma:
that's the thing I'll take
out the most. Yep.
[singing]